whether or not they're ghosts is an open
question i would bet that more people
have seen a ghost than have visited
south dakota and through through history
right we all believe south dakota exists
and whether we've been there or not
people tell us it exists it's on the map
we can read about it but we often do not
believe that ghosts exist and yet so
many people have experienced ghosts
first of all i don't actually believe in
south dakota
i've been to south dakota and i still
don't believe that it exists
as for ghosts i don't believe in ghosts
either nobody's produced any truly
compelling documented evidence of ghosts
i maybe call this the bigfoot conundrum
everybody's seeing them they have
beautiful hair but in in this day and
age when everyone's got cameras somehow
he never ends up on camera why are there
so many stories well because as human
beings we tend to detect agency
in things even when it isn't there your
mind tricks you into thinking that
everything that's happening there's some
sort of agency behind it boom roasted